i'm shoshanka ceo of actual data before
this spent a decade in data um first
half of my time at linkedin
was actually building a lot of data
infrastructure data pipelines data
platforms
i actually ended up fragmenting
linkedin's data ecosystem
and then
the next six years of my time at
linkedin was actually atoning for all of
my sins by putting all of these things
together using datahub as a single kind
of pane of glass on top of which people
could do data discovery data
observability and data governance so
that's been my story at linkedin created
problems and then solved problems
and now i'm doing the same with data hub
for the rest of the industry yeah and
i'm maggie i am the community product
manager for data hub and prior to this
i've worked in everything from analytics
engineering bi engineering
i joke that i'm a recovering analytics
engineer just because i have the
i know all the ways that things can go
wrong so now i'm trying to atone for
those
those mistakes in my past
so yeah super excited to be here outside
of work i like to bake i like to cook i
like to run i have two beautiful dogs
tucker and marlow you come to office
hours i will show you photos you have no
choice
i'm also the proud parent of three wild
animals one of them is a dog
and the other two are humans but when
they howl together you can't actually
tell the difference
so we have a lot of
shared love for
long-tailed uh animals that hold a lot
and
it's important for the rest of the talk
you'll get it
so let's talk about data hub you've
heard a lot about it a lot of people
think that it's a place to go find data
and discover data
and really the simplest way to think
about data hub is that it's the number
one open source metadata platform for
the modern data stack
and if you look at our integrations
you'll probably see every single modern
data stack tool up there
in fact in a lot of cases there are some
legacy tools up there and some
postmodern tools as well because data is
messy and a lot of people have to
integrate with a lot of things
the other thing that we're very proud
about is the number of companies that
are adopting data hub obviously it
started out at linkedin a bunch of years
ago but now it's in broad use at
companies uh in the consumer space like
expedia and peloton but also in kind of
the more serious enterprise space like
optum and saxo bank
and we're seeing a lot of
folks like udemy also getting deep into
it with advanced data ops use cases so
we're really excited to see how the
breadth of use cases that data hub is
able to solve for different verticals in
different industries there are too many
companies and i'm really sorry if we
left you out of this slide
the full list is available on the data
hub project website
yeah and so let's talk about our
community for a second um over the past
year we've grown 10 times our slack
community
we actually just reached over 2 700
people so this is even on a date just
from yesterday
when so when someone joins the data hub
community i send a dm just introduce
myself help people get kind of settled
in also ask them you know what brought
you here
and you know what are you excited about
and so really what we find is that the a
good portion of community members are
data engineers
also software engineers we have solution
architects coming in
um
as well as uh
oh sorry systems are system architects
excuse me um we're also starting to see
more pms come in data scientists come in
so we're you know kind of rounding out
the uh variety of personas that are
coming in here we are truly a global
community our slack community is active
at all hours of the day uh which i
should probably turn off my phone from
time to time but not today
and then in terms of our contributions
we in the past 12 months had 97 distinct
contributors just in the last month
alone we had 42 in a single month and i
think about half of those were actually
first-time contributors so it's a
combination of folks who have you know
been around for a while contributing to
the project but also people that are
coming in and are excited to contribute
to it there
one of the recent things that happened
that uh maggie is very excited about is
that on our latest uh monthly town hall
so we do a town hall every month
and on the latest well the one before
this on february i think
we broke the internet or rather we broke
zoom because we had what we thought was
a pretty expensive zoom subscription but
turns out it wasn't enough because more
than 100 people showed up for a monthly
town hall and they were harassing like
they were asking us on slack
that there's too many people on the zoom
can you please kick some of them out
and so now we have a more expensive zoom
subscription so congrats zoom nice
growing pains to deal with yeah
all right so but we're here to talk
about data discovery and data hub is an
important part of it
but as an industry you know this term
data discovery has been around for a
while
in fact i was doing a little google
search earlier this morning to see
when is the first occurrence of data
council and data discovery
together it turns out in
2018 was the first time there was a talk
done about data discovery
it was a team that had
obviously solved the problem
and they presented it at data council
but then when we talk to the community
that still continues to pour into the
data hub slack channel and we ask them
what's not working clearly a lot of
things still are not working with data
discovery which is why people are still
kind of coming in and trying to find
solutions to their problems so we are
here unfortunately as lemony snicket
says not to give you good news
but to give you some bad news we
actually need to rethink data discovery
a lot of the ways in which we've been
doing data discovery
aren't quite
working out
but there's hope there's hope
we obviously talked to a bunch of
companies and maggie has been doing a
lot of interviews and she came up with
this idea to create a fictional company
so tell us all about it so given
my obsession with dogs and animals in
general and me forcing that on the rest
of the team we created a fictional
company called long tail companions
where every pet is exceptional
so we're going to go through we're going
to use this as kind of a use case and go
through kind of their evolution of their
tech stack and the discovery problems
that came along the way
but one thing i will call out is that
this is really compiled and
representative of the outcomes of
conversations i've had with literally
hundreds of community members about you
know what their tech stack is the
problems they're facing why they showed
up in the first place
so
um longtail companions set out to adopt
or match every pet with every human
across the nation
so first they started with an adoptions
team and their focus was really to do
just that find a pet find a human match
them up together
and they hired a few engineers
to build that product and the engineers
basically said well we've got to store
you know
you know information about a pet and we
have to store
kind of when
someone signs in match them up with a
pet and then finally when an adoption
happens we need to record the fact that
this pet was adopted by this person and
they picked you know familiar tools from
the stack uh postgres for storing kind
of the more uh authoritative source of
truth data for an adoption actually
happening and mongodb is kind of a
flexible document oriented store because
you know pets need profiles and humans
need profiles and they weren't quite
sure what the schema of these things
would look like so they kind of went
flexible and said well json works
so that's how they built out a very
quick adoptions app and it worked well
yeah and the adoptions team just the
adoption program just exploded it was
fantastic but then they realized oh my
gosh we need leashes and dog food and
cat food and so they spun up an
e-commerce team to provide a supplement
to the very successful adoption program
and of course the e-commerce team said
well we need a place to store purchases
that are happening
and you know record every single
transaction as it happens and of course
postgres works we have a team that knows
how to operate and run it and so they
chose postgres for that table or the set
of tables
but they also realized that they were
bringing up an app and a website and
people are going to be clicking around
and they're going to be searching for
stuff and then
you know we want to recommend maybe
items that are better than others
because people who like labradoodles
typically buy these kind of bows things
like that
and so they said well we need an event
stream and so they
heard about this amazing technology
called kafka that makes event streaming
very easy to use and they adopted kafka
as their event streaming platform so
the e-commerce team has got postgres and
kafka and the adoption team has
postgres and and life is good
right yeah it's pretty good and then
they realize okay we're hitting some
scale issues with our the data that we
have so let's bring on a data platform
team
that focus will be on landing data in a
central lake and making it more
actionable and the data platform team
looked around found a few operators they
could get from airflow to take data from
kafka and land it into the lake a few
more operators to take data from
postgres landed into the lake
and they did it and they did it it was
working everybody was happy
and then they hired they realized that
okay now the data's in our
in our warehouse we actually need some
people who know what to do with that
right so they hire out an analytics
engineering team who of course is
adopting all the kind of modern best
practices of dbt for transformations
great expectations for validation and
then looker for a presentation layer
so
hopefully this is a common kind of
paradigm something that you can maybe
kind of like
feel uh related to a little bit and it
worked you know everyone was making the
best decisions for their own uh their
own use cases
but at the end of the day we actually
saw that the long tailers still had a
bunch of questions that popped up so for
example on the adoptions team they would
ask what happens if i if i need to make
a change or a breaking change to this uh
to the pet profile table what's going to
break down stream and it was a really
hard thing to figure out because
everything was so siloed and fragmented
so they'd drop a column cross or cross
their fingers close their eyes and just
pray that nothing
fell apart from there
and the e-commerce team also had a data
science team and the data science team
was busy building models and training
them and shipping products to the site
that could actually lift ctr or enable
better conversion from an item being
shown to actually being purchased and
one of the things that the long tail
founders
really
were serious about is not mixing
adoptions data with e-commerce data
because there was a commitment that they
had to the community that when you as a
human come in and adopt a pet we're not
going to sell stuff to you if you didn't
actually give us consent to use your
data
and so the e-commerce team was always
nervous about
are we using data in the right way are
we incorrectly mixing in adoptions data
from the adoptions teams data sets maybe
a derived data set and they were always
nervous about releasing a model
especially a model that was doing too
well because they were like maybe maybe
there's some personalized data in there
and that's why this model is doing well
yeah but they didn't know how to solve
that problem and then we move on to the
data engineering team
well the data engineering team is my
past life and these teams
end up being
the responsible team for producing a
data set or a set of data that the rest
of the company can really reliably rely
on and that ends up being
pipelines have to be running on time and
have to land data accurately every
single day and if you're doing hourly
pipelines they have to land every single
hour and the thing that they were
nervous about was by the time they
noticed problems it was too late
when they tried out their discovery
solutions you know
things were just never fresh and things
were never accurate and so they were
really running
around
headless chickens maybe it's a
reasonable analogy here
to figure out why is the data broken
which data sets to worry about and
whether a particular data set is
actually ready to be consumed by a
downstream team and we're not talking
humans here we're talking pipelines and
programs which means there are trains
running on a schedule and there's no
person kind of saying now is a good time
to go so it really has to be low latency
and drive kind of that automated action
and then of course our analytics
engineering team they're on a deadline
they need to build something out like
yesterday and they want to understand
what's the authoritative pet data set i
look in our
data warehouse in our data lake there's
hundreds and thousands and thousands of
assets i have no idea what to trust
and so it just becomes kind of like a
like this one is very near and dear to
my heart where it's just a lot of time
and energy spent just trying to figure
out what is safe and reliable for me to
use
and then finally
they're the execs you know every company
needs one or a few of them
sometimes they're pointy-haired and
sometimes they don't have any hair
but they all have the same worries and
the same problems
are we you know they quickly bought a
bunch of sas tools um and then started
shipping data up there
you know marketo mailchimp there's a
bunch of sas tools that really enable
you to get productive very quickly and
they're just always worried
are we sharing pii data up in there
and not managing our data responsibly
how much
you know data leakage do we have if
something upstream uh wants to do an
opt-out am i actually respecting it
end-to-end
and then last but not least we have our
our beloved business stakeholders whom
without we would not have jobs because
we are building resources to support
them and they come in and say wait a
minute this return rate calculated over
here is different from that one why is
it different i'm losing trust in the
data
so how do we go about actually you know
building out um or providing additional
context and additional resources to
instill that trust and you know help
people actually make decisions off of
this data
so again these are just the questions
that would come up again and again with
the uh the long tailers
and this is due to a very common and
typical data catalog story
yeah and this the words data discovery
data catalog they're often used
interchangeably and we'll use them the
same way but a typical data catalog
story that we've seen play out time and
time again in different companies at
different stages of adoption is
the data catalog gets installed
it's typically architected to connect up
to every single source of data and
metadata that there is it starts
crawling it pulling all of this into a
central place
and then there's a web app on top of it
and data consumers go in there and start
adding documentation knowledge tagging
people tagging data sets and hoping
that things are going to get better
but what tends to happen
is what we're finding is it just doesn't
work
after that first excitement of
installing this thing and bringing it on
board and integrating everything all of
which are really valiant efforts and
worthwhile
the catalog or the data discovery
solution starts becoming stale people
start losing trust in it because the
real action is somewhere else it's
happening every single time someone
edits a dvt model every single time
someone goes and creates a new looker
dashboard every single time someone
changes a schema on an online postgres
table and a lot of that isn't getting
captured here and so this becomes yet
another tool
in maybe the common data stack
that you have in your ecosystem and it's
now yet another source of problems yes
so why is this happening yeah let's dig
into some of the issues that come along
with that so um first and foremost
physical metadata if you start with that
and are troll like focus solely on
representing the physical structure of
data that's not intuitive or easy to
understand for a wide set of
stakeholders so it solves a very narrow
set of problems
and then a few other things that show up
is
a lot of catalogs are reliant only on
crawl based ingestion which means
they are going to connect up to the
source of metadata and then pull it down
and this is good to get started but it's
not good forever because things are
changing all the time and by the time
you actually find that something has
changed from you it's too late
the second thing that goes along with
this being able to observe changes in
real time is being able to act on those
changes in real time even as we are
giving this talk a few airflow pipelines
probably finished running and a few of
them probably ran successfully and a few
of them probably failed someone probably
checked in a backwards and compatible
schema change
while this talk was going on and if you
don't know about it now
you cannot prevent bad things from
happening now you'll only prevent bad
things from happening tomorrow or maybe
next week and by that time the damage is
done
yeah and then um another big problem
here is uh an over emphasis on manual
enrichment or kind of like post hoc
enrichment so you slurp up all this
metadata then a human goes in and kind
of annotates or cleans it up but then if
you don't maintain that it's immediately
stale i can't tell you how many times i
personally have done this myself
thinking this now that now that i've
created this google sheet this will be
where we are maintaining all of our
definitions for the rest of time and
it's still the next day
so an over reliance on on kind of like
the manual uh site of enrichment
enrichment is a huge huge problem with a
typical approach
and then finally a lot of data catalogs
only focus on the data warehouse
yesterday i was up on stage here talking
about definition of a data set
and a lot of us agreed that data sets
don't live and die in the data warehouse
they actually begin their life all the
way on the left where your production
systems are running and creating new
tables new kafka topics
name it
and then they get transformed in the
streaming data ecosystem and then they
come to the warehouse and then they get
transformed a bunch more and then they
leave the data warehouse and go into
your third-party systems and so if you
just
focus all your attention on the data
warehouse
it's important but it's not telling you
the full story and that leads to kind of
these end-to-end use cases not working
out yeah so we've
told you a common story something that
should be familiar with you we've told
you all of the ways that there are big
problems with it so what are we
proposing if there are three things that
we want you to walk away from in uh in
this talk
it's metadata360 oop
there we go
uh streaming metadata and shift left so
these are all very buzz wordy but we're
going to go through these one by one and
start breaking it down a little bit
so what does this look like in practice
we're going to start with metadata 360
and before we go into the kind of demo
there just want to talk through this a
little bit this is saying that metadata
is it requires a holistic view of what's
going on going on across systems and
across the business so it's not just
your technical metadata it's not just
your business definition it's tying all
of those pieces together for a very um
kind of like cohesive story of of what
it represents
so this is a view if we're looking at
this use case of how is return rate
calculated
this is going into data hub and we're
going to search for return rate
and then what we see is there's actually
two uh terms here and maybe i'm not
actually familiar with those so i'm
going to go to a dashboard that i know
and love the available pets dashboard
and immediately i can see that this
dashboard is assigned or associated with
this return rate and in here what i now
see is a plain language definition of
what it represents and also the sql
logic that that composes it i also have
quick access to see who owns it so i can
reach out to ask questions if i need to
but it's really just pulling everything
together in a single plane
so i know there's a very quick little
recording so let's actually look at this
a little bit closer
so for folks that are using dbt a common
way of documenting assets is by using
the docs macro so what we can do on the
left is specify that next to the
analytics and like within the analytics
engineering code so as as these terms
evolve as these definitions evolve it's
right next to where those folks are
actually working it's not in a google
sheet it's not in confluence or a wiki
page or whatever it's right where you're
working
so once we've checked this in on the
left
we can now automatically slurp that up
into data hub and present it within that
kind of like holistic picture so as
things evolve it's evolving within the
code and we're representing that within
the ui
um so on the same in the same vein of
physical and business metadata it's
starting to ask a question of what's the
authoritative data set and let's be real
like
none of us in this room have a
definition of what an unauthoritative
anything should be within data it's all
about context and understanding how it's
used how it's produced and
you know kind of like the operational
metrics along with it
so if i want to understand the
authoritative pet data set
i can either go into the main browse
page and start to browse by data asset
type or across all of my platforms or i
can just go into the unified search
experience and type pet
so automatically i have a facet
experience where i can start to filter
down by
either type so data set or chart or
dashboard whatever you want by platform
i can also look by domain so for your
data mesh folks in there we can search
by that
but here i know that i just care about a
snowflake data set and i want to find
the right pet one right so i see pet
details but here's pet profiles this one
looks pretty promising
so what i see in here is the column
table schema definition i have access to
recent and top queries that have been
executed so i can contextualize how this
is being used within the organization
i can also look at
data profiling stats to understand the
shape of data as it is today i can also
look at it as it was yesterday two days
ago three months ago and understand how
that has evolved over time
so we have it both at the table level we
also have it at the column level so you
can see what the distribution of null
percentages or distinct percentage et
cetera
and then the other thing is again tying
it back to these owners and domains and
now i see that this pet adoption
is part of this business critical core
pet adoption
domain so this gives me a ton of
indicators that this is a really good
place for me to start and not all of the
other 1700 000 million pet related data
assets that we have within our stack
so if we
okay let's dig in just want to do like a
little zoom in because i know that was a
quick demo so this is our data profiling
page my guess is it's a little bit hard
for folks to read in the past or sorry
in the back
but really what we're showing is just a
high level
uh snapshot of what the shape of this
data looks like i know that when i do
data discovery the first thing i'm doing
is looking at row counts volume
distribution of columns we have that
here for you and then we can also
transverse that over time to see how
it's evolved
the next part again is just the top
query so it's contextualizing how this
data set is used within your
organization just kind of further
bolstering your understanding or your
confidence
and then super exciting we just rolled
this out uh within the last month or so
we're now
integrated with great expectations and
additional
data validation plugins to come but you
can see all if you're if you're working
with great expectations you can see the
validation outcomes uh you can kind of
double click into it to understand what
failed what happened what the actual
outcomes were there
so again this is truly like a 360 view
of how this is used within a company how
it's used other data sets plain language
definitions and then tags out to
relevant relevant terms or
domains
the thing i like about this
is how
business metadata which is traditionally
represented using glossary terms and you
know taxonomies
are being connected up to the physical
metadata which is you know tables and
columns and all of the operational
metadata that's being emitted by things
that are running for example one of the
things that you might have noticed or
not are that airflow pipelines and tasks
are part of that search experience and
as we go into kind of lineage demos of
data hub uh you'll be able to see that
they actually show up in the end-to-end
lineage yeah
um so first we talked about metadata
360. now we're going to talk about shift
left
what does that mean shift left is
basically saying in an end-to-end
pipeline shift your focus on
documentation and enriching with
robust metadata
by um by extracting that from the source
code so don't annotate at the end shift
it all the way to the beginning and
extract as much as you possibly can from
there so um
with the question of what happens if i
if i push a breaking change to this data
set um i know personally i have merged
many breaking changes and have just
prayed to the gods and it has always
backfired so
one thing we can do here is our impact
analysis
whereby
because we have extracted all this rich
metadata from the source code we're able
to stitch everything together within a
lineage graph and in here i'm looking
for pet profiles
i'm looking at the source code so
mongodb
and i see that yep okay this is exactly
what i'm looking for this is uh you know
has the tags i'm looking for it's owned
by my team and i'm ready to see what the
impact will be so if we look at just
this quick lineage view it just shows
one dag downstream seems like very
not that big of a deal right but if we
go into our impact analysis we start to
see that there are literally hundreds of
entities that are potentially impacted
by this and then we can start to slice
and dice and and start to better
understand what that those would be
so that same kind of faceted search
experience so then if we look at data
sets maybe i want to like a sanity check
to make sure that okay this is something
that i'm familiar with or i want to
understand what it is we have an in
context way to view that entity
in its own context right so now i see
this beautiful dog zara is still up for
adoption someone adopt this dog please
what are we doing and i don't want to
break something that would sabotage that
right so i go into the impact analysis
again and i can
actually start to export all this
information so i know exactly who to
talk to
by downloading the csv we get the full
set of impacted entities
and you'll see
that
you know we have information about who
owns it their email address so i can
reach out to them directly we have
information about the tags or terms or
data domains that they're a part of
and it really allows us to be much more
proactive about pushing out these
changes and not just simply praying to
the data gods and hoping for the best
so one thing that maggie hopefully
convinced you about is shifting left in
terms of
moving your focus
not just on the data warehouse but
actually moving your gaze leftwards into
production systems and being able to
understand left to right what is the
impact of something that changed
the other thing that we're really
excited about is representing metadata
as code and what does that mean it means
applying
usual software engineering practices
to data logic as well as metadata
what that looks like in practice
especially for long tailers is being
able to
version their schemas as well as the
metadata attached to those schemas as
code
so
a quick body count again how many of you
have actually worked with kafka in your
current job or previous jobs
all right cool so this will probably
look familiar to you um kafka usually
people use it with schemas for the
topics but data sets in kafka are topics
they are streams of events that are
continuously changing
and usually you attach schemas to these
topics and those schemas could be
written in either avro or protobuf or
json schema and please tell me you're
not using the bytes option which is an
option but please don't use it so once
you decide to use a schema language and
in this case you know long tailers were
x google so they like protobuf
they decided to use protobuf and this is
what you know the the structure of the
e-commerce kafka schema registry has
checked into code looks like
the you know there's a top level
directory um there's a common area for
storing you know common objects and then
the e-commerce team has their own kind
of area for their topics that they
maintain
we've got three up here there's a click
event when you click on an item uh
there's an impression event when you see
an event uh see an item and then there's
a search event this is when a search is
rendered
so let's look at uh what these events
look like
uh seems should seem again very familiar
to people who are living and breathing
protobuf but for people who are new to
it i'll do a quick gentle introduction
on the right is the top level event
search event it's basically
a structured
record which has an event context which
is over here on the left it's kind of a
common header that all events should
have you know things like the device id
the device type user id ip address
timestamp things like that you want that
on all your events so you create a
header and you include that in each of
your events and then the search event
obviously has a few more elements like
the list of results of the search
and a few other things
but in addition to just that structure
you'll see something interesting in this
protobuf definition there are a couple
of additional annotations that have been
added in
which are marked as options you'll see a
classification option that's been added
called classification.send
and you'll see an option for a team
which says e-commerce
over to the left on the event context
common struct you'll see another option
on the ip address field saying that the
classification for that field is
classification.sensitive
now what and this is actually a
contribution from david works at zendesk
and contributed this amazing feature
into data hub
is the ability for
there to be schema annotations living
side by side with protobuf schemas
and these allow you to put business
context and business metadata in line
with your schemas
now you can imagine
you can have schema linters that
validate that all of your stuff actually
has annotations if you wanted to
and more importantly
every time one of these schemas gets
checked in and deployed your ci cd
system whether you're using travis or
github actions or whatever can actually
build and push these metadata artifacts
to data hub and that's where kind of
data hubs architecture shines i'll go
into that later but coming back to what
this looks like on the ui you go and
search for the search event and what you
will find is individual elements from
those schemas have been directly mapped
into tags or terms or documentation
which means there's no more of this
something got checked in now we have to
go to the ui and fix it up
you're basically shifting left all of
your metadata acquisition activities so
that you can catch bad metadata before
it makes it
into your data ecosystem yeah and for
folks that are using dbt we have this
exact same functionality in place for um
for assigning meta components so if you
are classifying your your models that
way if you're assigning ownership that
way we actually just automatically map
that for you back to kind of like the ui
so again it's maintaining all of those
things in code and not having to do it
post hoc
um quick time check sri shanka we have
about 10 minutes i think sounds good um
so we are going to zoom through the rest
of this so we've talked about two things
so far
metadata is 360. shift left and now
we're going to talk about streaming
metadata
all right so you've heard this multiple
times
your data is changing all the time
and as is your metadata which means if
you want to solve questions like
is this data set reliable can i use it
right now and if you're a program that's
about to kick off it's really important
for you to have metadata at your
fingertips that is live and trustworthy
and what we observe time and time again
is that
just having metadata 360 and just having
shift left principles is not enough you
actually need a platform
that can keep up with the volume and
velocity of changes that are happening
in your data fabric because this is not
just a schema changed it's actually a
lot of volume of operational metadata
that you need to be able to handle
so i'll zoom through really quick
through the data hub architecture this
actually is a one-hour talk by itself
catch us at office hours and we'll geek
out about graph databases and key value
stores and change data capture it's a
lot of fun and this was my past life
i've written a blog about it feel free
to check it out they're really three
generations of architectures when it
comes to architecting data catalogs or
metadata systems
generation one
was the whole crawl based systems they
connect up to systems bring it in
monolithic web app
inflexible opinionated data model
works to an extent doesn't work forever
the second generation was kind of
elevating the service aspect of it still
inflexible but at least now you can
write to the metadata store and it's not
just crawling stuff so an improvement
but still suffers from a lot of problems
because of the monolithicity of it
the third generation which is where data
hub really is
believes in a loosely coupled stream
oriented architecture what that allows
you to do is move metadata acquisition
and metadata production
where it's happening and allows you to
actually integrate your entire
common stack ecosystem into a single
aggregated data fabric
in practice this is what it looks like
the architecture allows you to have all
your data sources up into the left
producing metadata at whatever volume
they want it can be either crawled in or
pushed and we don't distinguish between
the two
all of this metadata gets into the
central metadata storage and the graph
and powers
both front-end experiences the app a lot
of the demos that you saw today as well
as programmatic use cases maybe a
compliance job kicks off uh wants to
fetch compliance metadata before it goes
and cleans data up maybe there's an ml
feature store that wants to fetch in
additional metadata about a feature
before it starts serving
and then for stream integrations you can
actually subscribe to changes that are
happening to your metadata in real time
the storage architecture is polyglot
and and and poly
index
we support key value stores as the
primary source of truth typically mysql
there's a kafka log that comes out which
is the change of a change log or commit
log of events that have happened to the
metadata stream which feeds
internal indexes like the search index
the graph index as well as a time series
index
as well as external
integrations such as anything that wants
to listen and subscribe to the list of
changes that are happening
so end to end the streaming metadata
platform really enables what we consider
the control plane for data
on your left you've got all of these
different systems that are producing and
making changes to your data ecosystem an
airflow job running a spark job running
a schema getting checked in
a table getting created all of this
stuff produces changes
data hub's job is to observe all of
these changes store it responsibly in
the largest metadata graph we can get
version every single change
allow refining these changes there's a
lot of entity resolution that you have
to do to actually standardize some of
this metadata across these systems
and then allow you to query the metadata
at rest so you can do version queries or
you can do point-in-time queries as well
as react to these changes that are
happening and so the potential obviously
is enormous
in terms of what you can do when you can
subscribe to changes you can fire off a
slack alert you can fire off a jira
ticket you can maybe even fire off a
great expectations run to validate the
data that just landed
the possibilities are endless and we're
just getting started and we think this
is going to unleash a new set of use
cases on top of the metadata fabric so
we started with the talk with talking
about discovery
and where we landed
is kind of active metadata management
which is what streaming really enables
you can do things like tag propagation
impact analysis versioned
lookbacks into your history of data and
metadata and here's a quick
demo of what time travel for schema
history looks like on the data hub
backend so this is basically a cli
experience
whoa
how do i play the video
oh
or maybe it is
all right so that's the cli and
um
so you're on the console you've got the
data hub cli and you can basically ask
questions about any data set and ask for
changes that have happened to its
technical schema or to its tags or any
kind of business
uh change that has happened to the
definition of the entity and what you
get back is kind of a versioned timeline
of changes that have happened to it
think of it almost like
a facebook feed for what happened to
this entity but really a log of changes
that have happened to it
but you can think of it more as
important changes being highlighted in
red for example as you see here
a backwards incompatible change was made
a particular column got deleted so
despite all of the impact analysis work
that that team had done they they
removed a column and you can kind of see
it and you see the versions go up which
means as a as a programmatic interface
you can actually depend and
halt downstream pipelines if a backwards
incompatible change has been detected in
a schema
the second thing that is also very
interesting is you can do tag
propagation with a system like this so
on the very left you've got a mysql
table and then you've got a kafka topic
that's the cdc for it and then finally a
bigquery data set we can go into the
mysql table add a particular
classification tag to it
and as soon as we add it in
because of the policy set by the
administrator the tag can actually
propagate down to the kafka data set and
then propagate down the bigquery data
set what this means is you as a human
don't have to repeat yourself you don't
have to go from data set to data set to
data set and annotate each one of them
manually by hand
you can annotate at source and things
will just automatically get taken care
of you in real time and the
possibilities for these are endless you
can build access control systems you can
stop
bad data in its track and you can enable
good data to actually flow to end
systems without getting blocked
by human processes
so we're back to the uh important and
one and only slide that you should
remember from this talk take it away
yeah so um if you want to go through the
three of them so just remember metadata
360 shift left streaming metadata those
are the three things that we want you to
walk away from
we are
so happy to have been here
we are so happy to have met all of you
please join our slack community join our
metadata movement
these are some ways you can get in touch
to or get in touch with us
thank you
[Applause]